I genuinely think that telling men to
like open up to women is bad advice
overall
so tell them to open but like I think
they should open up to other men do you
think so I agree because I don't I don't
want I look at a guy I want him to be my
rock yeah I don't I don't want a guy
that's more emotional than me but when
he crumbles all of a sudden it's like
who's this person how do I deal with it
because I've never seen this side I
never saw it coming and it's like whoa
whoa whoa now he's really soft and who
is this I'm not saying leave him the
second you see any emotion but I think
by and large like the more he does it
the more likely you will leave because
you don't like do women want weak men or
do they want strong men it doesn't make
you weak to open up and I think there's
a time and place and I think I think as
you said it depends on what the woman's
there for I think that also plays a part
because sometimes you know when you're
in a girl chat or I feel like sometimes
it does stem from I wouldn't say
actually it stems from any age range of
women or anything I think it's of a
perspective and how like you said you
want your man to be but nine times out
of ten I do feel like if a man opens up
or he gets emotional I feel like if
you've not been together for a very long
period of time or it's quite new women
tend to go yeah but I don't actually
know why he opened up to me like why is
he acting bear soft or like it's just a
bit like what do I do do you know what I
mean a lot of women do get turned off by
that kind of stuff yeah of course yeah
that's why it is always better to open
up with your boys yeah and sometimes
your boys just can't support you like
that yeah not always or even reach out
to a coach or a mentor an expert in that
field I'm not even just saying no but
that's that's actually the reason why I
got into it but like um yeah
unfortunately let's admit that your
words do get used against you in an
argument
and women do sometimes tend to go to
that that because when they want to get
a reaction out of you they want to see
some emotion they will go to that soft
place so I always thought I meant just
yeah not not to open up in front of your
girl and I think it goes back to like
all them like old-time sayings you know
like
you treat him and mean keep them Keen so
it's like that's what women like kind of
sometimes that chase and that play with
men I feel like they don't always like
what they want sometimes they like to be
put in their place they're like a man to
be able to know he can do that well and
I think it also goes back to like women
reproduce with aggressive men you know
that um felon violent felons have more
children than people that don't have a
criminal history wow not to do with
grape though I mean that sounds a little
sauce that they have a violent history
and then they have more girls look at
what happened to Ted Bundy when he was
in prison I know a bit that I feel like
that's a wild exception in general no
it's not an exception if you look at if
you take the percentage of men that
reproduce that are violent felons they
reproduce more than people without a
criminal history and when there's even
like a trend of women falling in love
with their captors or or pursuing those
men when they're in prison that's trauma
like that's trauma though it's Stockholm
syndrome is like pursuing your character
no I don't think it is I think it's
biology I'm not saying it's like a good
thing but why because because
historically what what happened we were
in tribes right and what would happen
you would be with the strongest man
because they would kill your man and
they would take you I don't know you had
to like learn how to beat fall in love
with the person that captured you if you
wanted to survive and reproduce just
like an anomaly here but like I could
not be with a man if he didn't open up
to me if he didn't have a soft side and
like if someone opens up to me early on
I take that as a positive sign that I've
made them feel comfortable I've never
ever ever judged someone for that and I
don't think that men should be trying to
be with the kind of women that would
judge them for that I agreed I would
never encourage my male friends to be
with a girl who would like snare at him
for crying yeah but I think by and large
like women lose respect for men the more
that they open up so I think it's like
from a feminine point of view where like
this is why they say women give bad
dating advice because across the board
women don't respect men that open up
more I think it depends on a lot of
factors like age and stuff like that
because I think maybe at 23 I would have
been like oh but no man at 45 he's had
children he's had trauma are you gonna
have people come with more stuff and I'm
more like 360 now and I would be able to
deal with it much more now than I would
be I wouldn't judge a man for opening up
to me now I mean yeah you might not
think you would no I really don't think
no but there's there's studies that show
that women lose respect for men the more
they cry the more they like that's one
way that men
of society right it's across the board
they've done multiple studies with
multiple different women in multiple
regions because think about it like we
don't we don't want a guy that's crying
every day not every day but like
something traumatic's happened to him
his dad died but see this is what this
is the thing though like every time I
bring up this example that's always what
women say it's like when his dad died
that's extreme
overall you still want a strong man you
don't want a guy that's crying every day
every day every day and we're doing like
once like there's a again there's a
spectrum okay so how often can he cry
like when the way often like when
something traumatic happens okay so how
often what if it's once a week you
staying no okay I would say I feel like
it I mean if it was going through a bad
patch or something and he's got
depression and like then again there's
different so three years he's depressed
every week he's crying that's going to
be tough but see that's that's my point
but if I I was crying every day for
three years that's gonna be tough it's
not for you know girls cry once a month
if you know what I mean yeah but that's
not every day for three years
no it depends on your preference now
you're right there's some women that put
up with more and there's some that put
up with less but if you're advising men
why would you tell them to do something
that most women don't like I don't want
them to be with most women though I'd
want them to be with someone who's going
to emotionally support them and love
them like unconditionally
women don't love unconditionally they
love under conditioning 100 yeah come on
if your guy was unemployed for 10 years
you're staying no not working sitting on
the couch it's always situational when
you know it with somebody but that's the
point see you you wouldn't but you would
it like if something happened to my
boyfriend if my boyfriend got cancer and
couldn't work and he was ill for 10
years would I leave him absolutely not
not in a million years I would say and
I'd support him but I wasn't talking
about the exception I'm talking about
the rule and one of the number one
indicators of divorce is financial
yeah because and women and actually one
out of six divorces women are spiteful
and wreck men in court
financially wrecked that means they
don't give them access to the children
and they also financially ruin them one
of every six divorces yeah but most men
don't like it's only like 20 of men try
to get access to their children why I
don't know why because they feel like
it's notified so they just don't bother
but why would you not fight if I had
lost control I don't have children but
if I lost my children I would fight for
them I wouldn't be okay like 80. I'll
tell you I'll tell you I'll tell you why
they don't fight so um I interviewed and
I'm doing a documentary on this okay so
I actually have spoken like I just did
one today
um
so basically what a girl can do is she
can put it's a restraining order I
forgot what you you guys a
non-molestation order yeah so so one
call right she can put in a
non-molestation order and say he abused
her and by the way she's incentivized to
say this so she gets Free Housing if she
says that he abused her and free um
lawyers
so one call he's out of his house
because he can't stay in the house he he
still has to pay the mortgage on and now
he doesn't get a court date for a year
so it takes him a year six months to a
year to even see his kid that she's not
letting him see and he can't even
legally go and try to see the kid Okay
then if he wants to so she gets free
lawyers and by the way these women's
shelters they know exactly what to say
so he cannot get access to the kids okay
um and so on top of that and this is
this women can do this too or men can do
this too but they're not typically the
first ones who file women file 80 of the
time 90 of their college educated so on
top of that if he wants to fight in
courteous to spend twenty to thirty
thousand dollars or pounds here would
your children not be worth 20. okay okay
okay
I'll get to it so the average guy makes
what 35 000 pounds so now he's in all
this debt trying to get his kids okay so
he goes to court and there's only a 10
chance of him winning
ten percent of the time so now he's just
and on top of that he's still paying the
mortgage on his house and on top of that
he he's now on child support so he's
probably paying like three four hundred
bucks a month on top of maybe a fifteen
hundred dollar a month mortgage so
that's almost two grand okay he's paying
a month and then he's got the court fees
this is where a lot of men kill
themselves yeah because they can't see
their kids there's only a 10 chance
they'll get primary custody he could go
through the whole thing and probably and
if he's lucky he gets six days a month
with his kid and she can do it all over
again with one call but if you take that
back to the beginning to get a non-mole
in the first place you need probable
cause he was violent no you don't no
yeah no you don't
you don't need any evidence there I know
a girl that got Free Housing and there
was no man that did anything like she
didn't have a boyfriend and she just
said that you don't need any evidence or
proof because the differences in family
court it's not based off of evidence
it's based off of a balance of abilities
and typically when women cry and say
they were abused the judge is just going
to believe her because again in family
court you don't need evidence where in
Criminal Court you do so the question is
why aren't these women in criminal court
now what percent of cases did the women
actually in in the women's shelters what
percent of cases did the women actually
file Criminal Court where Like a Man
actually got a jury a trial all about
what percent of cases do you think there
is well clearly if that system is
allowing them to lie then they they
won't while they're going for criminal
right but I'm saying so like if someone
punches you in the face most likely
you're going to go to court right yeah
right you would think right so what what
percent out of 10 women in these women's
shelters what percent of them actually
went to Criminal Court
maybe like five
yeah one under one it's actually it's
higher than you say it's like 15 to 20
so 80 of cases there's no evidence and
with one phone call she takes away as
kids and financially ruins him and now
he he's saying on top of the child
support he's paying on top of the the um
restraining order on top of all of these
fees on top of arguing at the mother for
a year he needs to fight for his kids
and pay 20 to 30 000 pounds for a 10
outcome you know what if I was a guy I
wouldn't do it I wouldn't you wouldn't I
think there's men that would go to the
ends of the Earth for their children but
I think there's a lot of men that don't
I I think that's easy to say in a place
of privilege but if you're making he at
this point most of the men are homeless
and on top of that their entire
Community thinks they're an abuser with
no evidence but are they homeless that
because you've said two things like the
woman's in the house and he's paying the
mortgage or is she in a woman shelter
which which one no no they go sorry they
go to the women's
um it's not women's shelter it's like a
women's uh charity to help Refuge
there's a name for it but it's like it's
a women's group basically yeah and so
she's in the house he's officially
homeless and now he's paying two grand a
month and one guy interviewed it was
actually the saddest interview he had um
three kids and he was a mile away and he
couldn't see them
um he was a mile away from them and he
this man was fighting but he lost his
job because he worked in electricity and
imagine if you're homeless and you can't
see your kids and now like mentally how
are you going to do that yeah and so
it's like it's like we have this
narrative and a lot of like feminists
honestly push this narrative where it's
like men need to be more men need to do
more why when the systems are against
them and he could go through all of that
not see his kid for a year one more
phone call she can just do it again and
sign him up for another year
and you know I think how long has he
expected to do that until he how long is
he expected to financially ruin himself
the average guy makes 35 000 a year that
costs more than thirty thousand what is
he supposed to do he doesn't have the
money
I think we're preparing I think going
back to what you said in terms of when
you were saying you'd want you'd push
your female friends to support men and
you'd want your male friends to go with
someone that does do that I think it's
kind of Devil's advocating what your
same reality is is that you have to
prepare the men around you for what can
happen which is that and I think there's
a fine line between having an opinion
off of what you would do and what
actually happens in society and that's
one out of six divorces that that
happens and they factor in um like women
that do it for like a good reason right
like maybe he actually was abusive or so
so they take out those but it's one in
six divorces
hmm
so
it's really depressing it's actually
really sad as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible